oh I like these because you can really
feel on top I have no idea of what
caviar really is we all know caviar
taste like cub I've never this isn't
like a known about I'm kind of freaked
out that it's basically just like eggs
I like the way the balls pop in your
mouth I'm intrigued because I just
didn't think there would be a cheap
caviar I thought it was all expensive I
think it's got a doubt in my mind I'm
going to know the difference between
cheap versus expensive caviar having
never eaten it before it's like a booger
that you need to flick off your finger I
got no read on this for smell this is
this a relatively odorless that kept
that thing for caviar touch it feels
funny oh it's really gross
well briny salty this is pretty good
it's a little oceany it tastes like the
juice at the bottom of an oyster hmm
like but that's part we're good mm-hmm
oh that's expensive because it tastes
straight-up like for China I'm leaning
towards this being low-end off the bat
I'll say it was probably a keyboard [ __ ]
I can already tell these are the cheaper
ones cuz they're big and bright I feel
like that looks nicer to me this is our
imagine caviar looks like when you see
it in like a pretty woman look at these
things boys I feel like Nemo is coming
out there's like licking a fish really
fishy mmm this one's very efficient who
and him explodes I didn't like that
it assaulted me
first one expensive Sanga one cheap
first one expensive second one basically
rich people first why I want to say with
expensive second while I don't want to
say what's a cheap one I agree with
everything you just said yes that I feel
look at that yeah I think the little
green guy is for pricing and what I
think was salmon realms probably cheaper
I think the first one was most expensive
yeah yeah don't waste your money go
donate that [ __ ] to charity the more
expensive staff from your work yeah it's
just it's there you can taste the
difference
if since I was talking for my mothers
teat I've been eating caviar
I would really know why it was good you
could taste the toner Wow just imagine a
nipple shooting out fish eggs and
there's a different spike
[Music]